hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembered so you don't have to and
welcome to another rendition of writers
of the story this is where I take the
first few episodes of a nostalgic show
let's see if it still holds up with that
said um Jesus with pork and beans I
fucking loved x-men this was the bad ass
cartoon that kids watched the cartoon
that made you feel tough and rebellions
but it actually had a good story and
good characters to back it up as well
but is it a story that still holds up or
if they're just too much corniness to
make it work now I know what you're
thinking
then the nostalgia chick already
reviewed the x-men cartoon what obscures
loop already to the room Mike J already
did jaws 3 and the distress watcher
already did Dungeons & Dragons why give
a shit now anyway it's not like I'm
gonna do my own dark nella side or
anything
well with that said let's take a look at
the first few episodes of x-men so the
show starts and I have to admit I get
the chills whenever that song plays I
hear nothing but awesomeness
if the coolest thing ever I get this
overwhelming urge to kick some ass
movie
huh
yeah
after that awesome opening we get our
first episode night of the Sentinels
part 1 we start off with the mutant
Sabretooth ooh
oddly enough has nothing to do with this
episode after throwing a car at a
cameraman who somehow filmed this entire
event completely still in miles high in
the air we cut to a concerned mother and
Ray from the Real Ghostbusters who are
talking about their daughter but how
could you register her with that mutant
Control Agency as if she were some sort
of criminal it's an outreach program to
help these unfortunate people let's just
hope the neighbors never find out our
beautiful Jubilees a mutant so this is
Jubilee a young girl who's always
dressed like she's about to do the
dishes in the rain the little do they
know that a mechanical visitor is about
to cross their paths
what if we were wrong what if she is on
you are you kidding
look what you did to the VCR just by
touching it well to be fair that's what
happens when most women touch a VCR ah
yeah come on get the VCR to stop
blinking 12:00 my Darrin I'm fucking
Gary
so this giant machine is known as a set
of a government built robot designed to
track down mutants um subtle you could
just send cops or military for something
like that but no we need gigantic killer
machines to apprehend teenage girls who
rated April O'Neil's closet are the
economy's in the toilet
good god
we can't upset what our policemen use
bad language how the hell would we ever
let this destructive can of Campbell's
and fly Jesus Christ the property damage
is unbelievable well sir did you keep
the receipt for them all oh then we have
nothing to discuss so it turns out the
mutant outreach program really is
designed to reach out and grab mutants
whether they like it or not
but fortunately this mall is also the
shopping place for a store
another new who I swear things that
she's energy are our Toki novel yes just
of the elements commands you to release
that child go back to the shadow
she helps save Jubilee along with
another mutant named rogue who I swear
to God has only gotten hotter with time
come in mama put me down you my freak
you will never have to put me down rogue
she's a series of payment lines southern
hold perfection and there's also the
Cajun gambit
where you going booty anywhere but here
who may actually have the strangest
casual wear out of all the x-men and
that's saying a lot
I mean sure Jubilee looks stupid but I
can at least tell what she's wearing
we've gambit with what is half that
stuff run girl Cyclops
so they take her back to Xavier school
for the gifted which ironically never
shows anybody teaching or learning
anything throughout the entire series
she breaks out of her room and starts
snooping around coming across other
mutants like beast um sort of closer
there you go and morph wait a bit morph
who the hell is more Bob fennel
Americans I am an idiot oh yes I forgot
morph was a character who was never in
the comics he was created specifically
just for the animated show why well so
he could die yeah I know I'm giving it
away but he was just made up so they
could kill he's basically just the
Michael Biehn of animated cartoons he
shows up dies we feel sorry and then we
totally forget about you might as well
just change its x2 r.i.p that's all he's
known for but I digress
Xavier the telepath who runs the place
figures out Jubilees escaped in of
course she panics three weeks
Oh randomly smashing the keyboard
accepted pity dish is no place for you
so she enters the danger room the
training grounds for the x-men drusus
just not exist in this world this places
every personal injury attorneys wet
dream and then we see everyone's
favorite badass himself there you are
I mean it nobody tops this guy in fan
acity how badass is he his voice is a
mix between the Dark Knight of Popeye
and yet he still bends I go where I
wanna go he hops around in yellow
spandex and a poorly cut Mickey Mouse
head and yet he's still bad
he gets an Australian Broadway dancer to
play him in the movie and yet he's still
badass he can strike this pose which I'm
comedic Lee going to play back and forth
right now and yet he's still fucking
bass in fact I put it to you has there
ever been anything
Wolverine related that has not been
entirely badass yeah but he was bad
accident so what's the first thing in
this show that this ultimate badass is
gonna do don't hurt him
okay that was a puss out but everything
else he's got his bass is the child all
right they were fighting and I wanted to
help him don't worry patty
you just heard Wolverines pride that's
all
speaking of pride should i be disturbed
that my outfit is Pinker than yours come
with me child I shall explain who we are
so storm explains to Jubilee as well as
the audience for that matter what
mutants exactly are no one knows who
will be a mutant at Birth we discover
our extraordinary powers at about your
age this sort of pinpoints our whole
symbolic prejudice thing
it's about gays let's get what they're
wearing
Professor Xavier is our leader and he
has named us the x-men this is Professor
Xavier school for the gifted and
hamburger University we x-men learned
something very special here Jubilee
mutants
benefits of mankind you know I forgot
how much of a fucking show up storm
could be sometimes it's like Harley
because we're powers could save the day
every time by just summoning or tornado
or something but no she uses lightning
bolts and I don't know moves clouds and
shit
this is actually a common complaint from
x-men fans and yeah pisses me off
next thing that ID photograph is from
the mutant Control Agency registration
files somewhere in there are the
registration files of hundreds of
mutants so we get em and we shred them
so we find out where the headquarters is
and decide it's time to take action
Professor Xavier we've been together for
a long time when you form the x-men was
it not to teach us to use our powers to
benefit mankind
professor aren't we I know what you're
going to say Cyclops but I'm afraid we
have no choice choice you're just
jumping into terrorism I didn't hear
anything else discussed you didn't even
talk about any other options but it
turns out Jubilee escapes again you know
for all their high-tech gadgetry they
sure do have shitty security and she
just walks by a gigantic killer robot
that surprisingly can manage a pretty
good hiding place
way have you ever noticed her powers are
pretty inconsistent she can Mack
Wolverine across the room almost take
off the head of a Sentinel and now it's
like dude that's annoying
don't make me step on your hand she gets
guests again and passes out just as the
rest of the x-men figure out she's gone
I'm going after no way Wolverine we've
got a job to do first out of the way
gumbo gambit let him go
he's now with Oh what the fuck don't you
ever look before you throw those things
what you're not even gonna turn around
okay fine
here's some laser in the back of your
head so the rest of the x-men go to the
mutant registration to carry out their
mission as they discuss something you'll
hear quite a lot in this shows angst
you're supposed to know everything beast
what makes it like we are anyway gamma
rays pollution ozone depletion
television progress really because I
heard from the conservative right that
we chose to be this way but it turns out
Wolverine joins the gang as he couldn't
find Jubilee and they sneak into the
place it looks like clear sailing from
here
and thus ends part 1 as we begin part 2
in the next episode oh wait
right after we have one of those classic
episode recaps just hope the neighbors
never find out our beautiful Jubilees oh
no help you
Cyclops there you are I'm not gonna kill
Jacob Ben you are chilled up red alert
Batman was tied to a mattress hi hey Bob
just what was happening in there as we
open in the next episode we see
Wolverine can smell the gun oil and they
bust their asses allowing them to sneak
in and destroy all the names in the
files
well that's going on we figure out the
location of poor Jubilee well we give
credit that does look like a typical
Detroit building wake up I want to ask
you some questions tourmaline and that
is a typical Detroit welcome you know
maybe the show is more realistic I give
it credit for me who are these so-called
x-man guy Rick why did you bring that
mutant here who is she I love it that's
the first question he asked there's a
girl strapped to a table obviously held
there against her will and his question
is who's that
that doesn't look like the other girls
would kidnap and hold hostage to my
castle so the files are destroyed the
x-men tried to escape Gavin blow that
fence
do playing that again a mature young man
he is right there didn't I tell you
they're sailing all the way lookout and
ironic twist what you just said Truong
Chi it's more can't you feel it
it's as if millions of expendable voices
cried out in terror and were suddenly
silenced I don't sense anything so we
get sort of a weird edit as we jump
forward to after the battle and we find
out that morph didn't make it and let's
be honest you're all a little happy I
mean if you had to hear this again
I got a happy soldier boy here left them
behind for all we know morph and Beast
may still be alive
beast is what about more well put it
together ape man let's see if Beast is
alive then morph beast is alive that
means more peace more beast morph
peaceful oh hey I get it out that really
sucks Wolverine
tell Cyclops I made him a convertible
what happened isn't his fault
it's not your fault either hey sweet a
convertible so Wolverine has a flashback
to just an hour ago again weird editing
every calls how morph was killed by just
a zap of the laser and yet bees get
zapped with the laser and electrocuted
on the fence and somehow comes out okay
beast and rogue get zapped - you know
what maybe more if it's just a pussy you
ever think that maybe he's just a giant
fucking pussy it's adamantium tasting
time boys please don't show this in the
commercial for the shop
I can see my house from there so we see
Cyclops tells the team to retrieve and
beast gets left behind I want to ask you
some questions another time it's your
funeral
I'll be back don't worry you'll only
stay in prison for the rest of the whole
fucking season seriously what was up
with that flesh to normal time and we
see that the President of the United
States was in on the whole Sentinel
thing all the time
Zhora he wanted to see me
Madam President I wanted to congratulate
you and dr. Trask I also wanted to tell
you to stop all activities involving
your privately run mutant registration
program why did they have good reason to
be threatened I don't know this still
seems fishy I just can't see a president
signing a bill allowing giant mechanical
robots to invade our personal freedoms
and okay y'all know where I'm going with
this but the x-men have a plan to find
the Sentinels base they lure one of them
out by showing up to Julie's house and
try to follow him surrender mutant of
course not
oh he's just pulled the knot line the
line every second grader used when he
knew for a fact that he had nothing
clever to say snap Cyclops trap
returning to base for repairs
also remember to replace the radio that
showed when I was obviously being
followed because I am probably obviously
being followed so the simple crash is
into the headquarters because I guess
it's hard to fly with one arm and this
allows Jubilee to escape only to be
caught again
she was pretty useless wasn't she
Jubilee duck how would their pansy
fireworks I have a pussy pink laser
ready to save us so Cyclops gets zapped
in gambits does his car tricks rogue
je-sus oh that's right it's ro she gets
up like she's wildly fucking coyote got
her she's so friggin hot that even the
Sentinels are humping the air looking at
her no I'm totally serious look oh yeah
this guy's harder than solid metal oh
yeah but then Wolverine comes in to stop
it oh come on man it's like guy rule
number four let him finish so even
though the bad guys get away they
destroy all the Sentinels and their home
base and welcome their newest decoy I
mean crewmember Jubilee to the x-men you
will come to visit us won't you
does a mall baby chili fries uh that's
bad 90s talk for no no if you they never
show up in the series again just assume
a dog
and thus ends the story arc of x-men
after so many years does it still hold
up well it's a pretty solid intro for
kids the characters are pretty well
introduced the idea of mutants and
Prejudice is well shown that it didn't
feel like a need to talk down to kids
too much okay there's a lot of things
that are silly and I'd be lying if I
said it met Batman or and a maniac level
but as kids shows go it holds up pretty
well it has decent action well-developed
characters a passionate story it was a
show that felt big every event that
happened felt like a big event there's a
lot of goofy moments but there's a lot
of kick-ass moments too and you can tell
that wasn't just another comic show that
was made for children they put a lot of
actual effort into it and it definitely
shows it may not be perfect but by god
if friggin awesome I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't
of course not